ils se sont offert une visite guidée
dans les vignes d'iran s'y confiner dans
l'yonne depuis le mois de mars
ces deux couples parisiens partent à la
découverte du pinot noir et du césar
deux heures de balade qui font du bien
au moral
on apprend plein de choses ce qu'on
croit savoir plein de choses sur le 20
mai en fin de compte c'est très
intéressant de pouvoir faire ses
ballades et en plus de faire des balades
après le confinement c'est quand même
très très chouette
vous montrez le petits gestes barrières
pour traquer temps des mois le plus de
vocations notamment et hop on trinque
comme ça et comme ça
pour les vignerons
ces visites dégustations au grand air
sont aussi une façon de relancer
l'accueil du public car aujourd'hui
encore les clients sont un peu réticents
à retourner dans les caveaux parmi les
activités qu'on propose aux domaines ont
fait des ateliers d'accords mets vins au
domaine mais on a un peu trop proche
donc celles ci n'ont pas repris mais les
balades voilà il ya ce plutôt simple
comprend bien les distances tout est
désinfecté avant chacun son matériel
donc c'est vrai que voilà y'a aucun
risque et aucune crainte
mais à quelques kilomètres de là à
chablis certains domaines restent encore
très prudents ici par exemple on ne fait
pas de dégustation seulement de la vente
et du conseil aux clients déguster c'est
aussi utiliser des verres utilisés des
crachoirs est temps pour nos salariés
que pour les gens qui viennent déguster
en tout cas dans cette première étape de
déconfinement il nous a semblé plus
logique de ne pas rouvrir la dégustation
puis c'est aussi un acte de solidarité
puisque les bars et des restaurants
restent fermés pour déguster les vins de
bourgogne en toute sécurité et avec
modération
il faudra certainement attendre le mois
de juin
reste à savoir maintenant si les
touristes seront au rendez vous